la copie corrigée a été rendu le 22
avril dernier alors qu'il s'exprimait
sur le nouveau protocole sanitaire mis
en place pour la rentrée scolaire du 26
avril le ministre de l'éducation
nationale s'est finalement prononcé en
faveur des purificateurs d'air après
avoir longtemps exprimé sa réticence
nous encourageons les collectivités pour
les capteurs de co2 et les purificateurs
d'air
cela fait d'ailleurs des mois que cela
s'est amorcée selon des modalités qui
varie d'un endroit à l'autre
nous sommes en partenariat avec les
collectivités chaque fois que cela est
pertinent
pourtant cela n'a pas toujours été son
discours en novembre dernier chez france
inter jean michel blanquer études à
l'appui balayé cette option d'un revers
de la main
évoquant l'inutilité des purificateurs
d'air voire même leur potentielle
dangerosité
il semble même que parfois ça renvoie le
virus moi je veux bien qu'on me démontre
le contraire
mais les études que j'ai à ma
disposition 10 cela des informations
quelque peu être démentie par nos
confrères d'ars t l'étude de l'insee est
brandie alors par le ministre évoque
certes parfois l'absence d'efficacité de
certains appareils mais tous ne sont pas
concernés par ce défaut en sont exemple
par exemple les appareils disposant d'un
filtre hp a dit à haute performance
invité du grand jury rtl lci le 25 avril
dernier jean michel blanquer a évoqué ce
changement de discours nous faisons
évoluer ce que nous disons en fonction
de ce que nous savons en france une
étude menée à l'échelon local en région
auvergne rhône-alpes démontre que les
filtres h au péage site capture le virus
du coc vite 19 à plus de 99% ces
appareils pourraient donc faire leur
apparition en mal dans les écoles comme
dans les établissements scolaires
allemands ou espagnols qui ont déployé
ces dispositifs
depuis la rentrée 2020